دمار واسع وبقايا
منازل على هذه الحال وجد سكان حي ابو
طعيمه منازلهم او ما تبقى منها في شرق
خانيونس
هنا وجدنا بشائر عادت بعد اسابيع لتقف عند
اطلال بيت دمر بما فيه من مقتنيات لعلها
تنتشل هي وطفلتها شذرات من ذكرياتهما من
تحت الانقاض طلعت وداره منيحه وما في فيها
ولا شيء طلعت وبيت ما فيش فيه ولا شيء كله
كويس رجعت شوفي كيف شوفي كيف الاواعي بدي
احاول اني اجيب شويه لبنتي اغراض شتويه ما
فيش كله رايح فش ولا شيء
ضاي صدمه السكان لجمت السنه البعض فصاموا
عن
الكلام ودفعت اخرين لمحاوله غرس الحياه
بين الدمار ايش بدك تسونا بالدار انه ابو
جهاد وزوجته الذان افترش جزءا من مدخل
منزلهما المقصوف بعد ان انهكه النزوح مع
اسرته واحفادهم مالقتش مكان اقف فيه ما
عرفتش ادخل البيت بكل باي طريقه و باخرى
دخلنا ونظفنا لنا مكان في بيت
الدرج نقعد فيه على اساس
نرتاح خذ نفسنا افضل من ال انه نضلنا في
في في المدارس
و واريح
نفس اكثر من 5000 مواطن يعيشون في هذا
الحي معظمهم مزارعون استهدف جيش الاحتلال
حيهم بحزام ناري فدمر المسجد والمدرسه
ومحطه تحليه المياه الوحيده فيه ومئات
الوحدات السكنيه ففقد معظمهم كل ممتلكاتهم
طول حياتنا بنشتغل
وبنقدم الحاجات هذه والحين ما لقينا منها
حاجه عا كله دمار كله اباده كله ما فيش لا
مخلين بني ادم حتى تطير حتى البني ادمين
الحيوانات ما في حاجه سلمت في حاجه سلمت
في الاماكن في كل الاماكن مش بس هنا في كل
اماكن فلسطين ما فيش حاجه سلمه عباده تحت
ركام هذه المنازل فقد سكان المناطق
الشرقيه في خانيونس كثيرا من احبائهم
وممتلكاتهم ومعها ذكرياتهم بعد ان دمر
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي احياء باكملها فوق رؤوس
ساكنيها لكنهم يقولون انهم مصممون على
استئناف حياتهم رغم كل الظروف القاسيه
التي مروا بها هبه عكيله الجزيره من ق
عبسان شرق مدينه خانيونس